ضدنا سيكون سريعا وصاعقا. الموت
يهدد مئات الاوكرانيين المتحصنين
كييب. روسيا تستهدف محطات السكك
الحديدية في اوكرانيا. لجنة
اخرى وتذكير كل من ينوي التدخل
من الخارج في الاحداث الجارية
لارسالها الى اوكرانيا. روسيا
تستخدم غواصات لمهاجمة اهداف
وتشكيل خطر وتهديد استراتيجي على
روسيا بان ردنا على اي ضربات
اوكرانية وخبراء يعتبرونها رسالة
للناتو. بوتين اود التنبيه مرة
مقابل طيار صفقة تبادلية بين
امريكا وروسيا. واشنطن تدر وضع
كل ما تملكه الطبقة الثرية
المحيطة بفلاديمير بوتين.
خرسون مؤكدا انهم سيبدأون
استخدام الروبل في خرسون في
تحقيق عراقية لا ادلة على وجود
نشاط تجسسي لاسرائيل في اربيل في
لبايدن ينادي فيه والدته
المتوفاة منذ الفين وعشرة ليضاف
من الخلافات والتوترات بين
البلدين الرئيس التركي اردوغان
حتى الان على اصابة البشر على
نطاق واسع. وبالتالي لا يزال خطر
الاوكران الذين يحاولون تخريب
السفن الحربية الروسية. جندي
روسيا. رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
قرار قطع امدادات الغاز خطوة
وممتلكات الاثرياء الروس ستستخدم
لتعويض اوكرانيا. واضاف سنصادر
عشر بينما قال اردوجان ردا على
تصريحات بايدن لنرى انها تستحق
حتى التوقف عندها لانها مبنية
على اكاذيب ومعلومات خاطئة بشكل
لسيادة كييف النازية ولا يوجد اي
خطط لتنظيم استفتاء في مقاطعة
الاول من ايار مايو. قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان اصول
لخرسون كيريل ستريموسوف الى ان
مقاطعة خرسون لا يمكن ان تعود
الى مواقفه وتصريحاته السابقة
والغريبة. كتيبة ازوفا
اكثر من اصدارات ابل في اجهزة
الهواتف المحمولة. ما كل هذا
التي فرضت عليها اثر غزوها
اوكرانيا. خلل في الدبابات. وزير
ايران عدوها الاول ولن تصمت على
امتلاك سلاحا نووي. دعم سخي. طلب
انفجار او مخزن الدبابة. وذلك
يعني ان اي ضربة ناجحة تشعل
هنا بدأ القلق والخوف يتملك
اسرائيل التي تعيش علاقات متوترة
وباء واسع النطاق منخفضا. لقد
اصبحت اسطورة الفيروسات في الصين
الذخيرة بسرعة مسببة انفجارا
هائلا بعد ان ينفجر البرج حرفيا
يدلو بدلوه بخصوص مزاعم الارمن
حول احداث الف وتسعمائة وخمسة
الوسائل لدفع امريكا لمنع ايران
من امتلاك نووي. وبعد هذا كله هل
ان اشار وزير الخارجية انتوني
بلينكن الى ان طهران سرعت وتيرة
تطور ايران سلاحا نووي في غضون
اسابيع. وجاءت تصريحات ساكي بعد
الماضي. توتر في العلاقات بين
برلين وكييف ودول اوروبية تقبل
بانه قد يستهدف ايضا
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين الذين
اخرى لكن ضد بولندا النووي
الايراني؟ مع تضارب الانباء بشأن
تحظو السعودية حذو ايران لتصنع
النووي كما وعدت فالسعودية تعتبر
المناطق الغربية من اوكرانيا
ستؤدي الى انشقاق البلاد فكيف
المحتملين في تحالف اصحاب
التفكير المماثل. وبينت
عن اي قصف او تفجير بجانب تلك
الدبابات والذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى
ترتكبه من فظائع وعدوان. نحن لا
نهاجم روسيا. نحن نساعد اوكرانيا
في ازوفستال فضلا عن مئات المرضى
ومئات الجرحى بينما يوشك الطعام
المخزن لديهم على النفاذ. في
محاولة لقطع امدادات الاسلحة عن
الدفاع البريطاني بن والاس يؤكد
ان موسكو فقدت ما يصل الى
موقع تم استهدافه في اربيل كبرى
مدن كردستان في العراق في مارس
الامر مكلف لكن واشنطن لا يمكنها
ان تقف على الحياد في مواجهة ما
السابق في تطوير علاقات بلده مع
روسيا. وقد الغيت رحلة كان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من
الكونجرس رصد ثلاثة وثلاثين
بناء على الالية التي طرحتها
موسكو. فهل تحذو بقية دول اوروبا
الراغبة ولم تتمكن وارسو حتى
الان من الاتفاق مع المشاركين
الامدادات. كما اعلنت النمسا
والمجر قبولهما بشروط روسيا
المناطق بدون تفويض من حلف
الناتو لكن بمشاركة الدول
جدا مع ايران. فلو امتلكت ايران
سلاحا نوويا فستنتهي عندها
بانفلونزا الطيور من سلالة في
مدينة بمقاطعة خنان بوسط الصين
برنامجها النووي. مشيرا الى ان
بلاده لا تزال تعتقد ان العودة
لخطة روسيا قطع الغاز عن بولندا
وبلغاريا. ذكر موقع بلومبرج ان
على ملاجئ ازوفستال. اشار نائب
رئيس الادارة المدنية والعسكرية
وفقا صحيفة ذا جوارديان
البريطانية. كما اشارت الصحيفة
الجنون يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
الاحداث والتطورات. مقطع متداول
يزور السعودية رسميا لفتح صفحة
جديدة وللمصالحة السياسية. موطن
ضرب اهداف عسكرية داخل روسيا.
حذر الكرملين من انه قد يستهدف
مواقع عسكرية في بريطانيا بسبب
الدعم البريطاني لاوكرانيا مضيفا
روسيا على قائمة الدول الراعية
للارهاب. كييف تشدد على حقها في
الاوكرانية تنشر صورا لمن قالت
انهم قتلى وجرحى جراء قصف روسي
يأتون الى العاصمة كييف. الحرس
الوطني الامريكي يجهز مدرعات
زالنسكي نحو خمسمائة الف من
مواطنين تم نقلهم قسريا الى
الاوبئة. كشفت السلطات الصحية في
الصين عن رصد اول اصابة بشرية
الى ان المؤشرات الاولية تقول ان
سلالة اتش توي ان ايت ليست قادرة
كامل. على السيد بايدن ان يتعلم
التاريخ جيدا فلا يمكننا ان نغفر
عدوانية روسية جديدة. روسيا تضع
دلافين مدربة لمواجهة الغواصين
له محاولته تحدي تركيا دون ان
يعلم الامور. اما اليوم وبعد زمن
التقارير البريطانية. اردوغان
يهاجم. دعا الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوجان نظيره الامريكي جو
بايدن الى تعلم التاريخ قبل ان
المتحدة زودت كييف بعشرة اسلحة
مضادة للدبابات مقابل كل دبابة
ولذلك فقدت موسكو مئات الدبابات
خلال المعارك في اوكرانيا بحسب
روسية ارسلت الى هذا البلد واكد
ان بلاده لن تسمح لروسيا بان
في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد العدوان
الروسي. لافتا الى ان الولايات
خمسمائة وثمانين دبابة منذ
انطلاق الحرب ضد اوكرانيا تقول
التقارير بوجود عيب في التصميم
فيما يعرف بموجة الصدمة الناجمة
ستكون ردة فعل الروس ان تم هذا
المخطط حقا؟ وهل نشهد حربا روسية
الاستخبارات الروسية ان الادارة
البولندية ترى ان سيطرتها على
تمارس ابتزاز الغاز للضغط على
الحلفاء الاوروبيين على العقوبات
الرئيس الالماني فرانك فالتر
شتاين ماير ينوي القيام بها الى
مليار دولار اضافية لحرب
اوكرانيا. وقال بايدن ان هذا
باسم البيت الابيض جين ساكي ان
البيت الابيض يشعر بالقلق من ان
تهديدات تل ابيب لطهران، لكن
اسرائيل تبذل قصارى جهدها وبشتى
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي هي افضل
سبيل لمواجهة النووية الايرانية.
الاوروبيتان بسداد ثمن الغاز
الطبيعي الروسي المورد اليهما
الروسية تكشف عن مخطط امريكي
بولندي للسيطرة على غرب
التوصل لاتفاق نووي بين القوى
الكبرى وايران. قالت المتحدثة
حذوا والمتجر لتكتمل خطة موسكو
بنجاح حرب محتملة. الاستخبارات
تواجه العلم بحقيقة اتمام وتطوير
ايران لسلاحها النووي خلال هذه
صفحة جديدة. بينما لقن الرئيس
التركي بايدن درسا في التاريخ.
مليار دولار لدعم اوكرانيا.
وبوتين يهدد برد قاس على اي تدخل
اوكرانيا. ووفقا للاتفاقيات
الاولية سيتم الدخول لتلك
لالمانيا. نقلت صحيفة بيلد
الالمانية عن مصادر في الحكومة
اربعة مشترين اوروبيين للغاز
الروسي دفعوا بالروبل مقابل
الاوكرانية ذكرها ان كييف الغت
زيارة المقررة سابقا بسبب دوره
لامداد الغاز مقابل الروبل
الروسي. قبلت الدولتان
والصين تعلن عن اكتشاف فيروس
جديد قد يجتاح العالم. لا قبول
المانيا للتقارب اكثر مع روسيا?
قطع شريان اوروبا. في اول نتيجة
العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف. لانه
على ما يبدو ليس موضع ترحيب من
الدبابات الروسية تم اعطابها في
اوكرانيا. فما هو السبب يا ترى?
الجانب الاوكراني. فهل ترتفع حدة
التوترات بين كييف وبرلين لتعود
للقبول بشروط بوتين. فهل تلحق
بهما دول اوروبية اخرى؟ امريكا
الغاز الروسي على بولندا
وبلغاريا بادرت النمسا والمجر
كرانيا. بايدن يعلم ان الامر
مكلف ولكنه يطالب بثلاثة وثلاثين
غربي بشأن اوكرانيا. اردوجان
يزور السعودية للمصالحة وفتح
بشروط موسكو ودعم امريكي متواصل
لاوكرانيا. فالى اين المصير?
لماذا رفضت اوكرانيا زيارة
المانيا لاراضيها؟ بعد قطع شريان
بوتين يجهز دلافين انتحارية
لحماية وغواصته من اي هجوم. مئات
الاسابيع. وموسكو تحذر من مخطط
امريكي بولندي للسيطرة على غرب